yes all is well on the international
stage um joe biden got lost in the wrong
cafe
how are your meetings going here in
cornwall
they all are laughing at him
unbelievable
joe biden has been abroad the big
problem is joe biden doesn't actually
know he's abroad
essentially joe biden's tenure thus far
is a lot like the anthony hopkins movie
the father
he's just wandering around not knowing
where he is and confused
all the time it's essentially an outtake
from the super bowl of the weekend
wandering through mirror-lined hallways
weirdly bumping into things
that is joe biden abroad and we were
told of course that donald trump had
shamed america on the world stage and
now america is
back baby america's back in fact anthony
blinken
the secretary of state he says the
foreigners love us again
the europeans they love us they love us
some yeah you know what the europeans
love they love when you give them what
they want
because politics is a power game and the
reality is the europeans know that joe
biden
thinks more like they do here is anthony
blinken
there was a major poll that just came
out that showed that across those
countries
75 percent of the people on average
now have confidence in american
leadership uh and in president biden
that's up from 17
a year ago so we're now in a position
where when it comes to dealing with
russia and the challenges it poses
or dealing with china and the challenges
it poses we can
come with a much more uh united front oh
is that what's going to happen in the
united front or maybe it's that the
europeans are comfortable that we have a
daughtering old fool in the white house
who's never going to challenge any of
their preconceived
notions about either russia or iran
about the middle east
they're just gonna do whatever the
europeans would like them to do and why
exactly would they feel threatened by
joe biden
i mean this is this is the key to joe
biden he is perfectly unthreatening
because again
near corpses are not threatening this is
why the right
is not really glomming onto attacking
biden because how do you attack
a house plant as i've said many times
before so joe biden over and over
on this trip he demonstrated that he is
in fact barely sentient i mean it's
it's embarrassing there are folks in
america who said that donald trump was
an embarrassment on the world stage
because he was so brusque and because he
said crazy things not
fine it is embarrassing to have a
president of the united states
who is wandering into walls okay that is
we've gotten to a certain point in
american life when these are the people
that we choose to be presidents of the
united states okay so
joe biden led off the g7
by mixing up libya with syria three
times he was trying to talk
about how he was standing up to the
russians and also we're going to work
with the russians to
end the bloodshed in syria but he missed
by 1400 miles
libya is nowhere near syria in fact it's
not
technically even on the same land mass
syria is up there in that middle eastern
landmass and libya is down there in
africa here is joe biden missing the
mark by oh
about 1400 miles three times in libya we
should be opening up
the the the passes to be able to go
through
provide provide um food assistance and
economic ass i mean
and for example the rebuilding of uh
of syria of uh of libya of
you know this is they're there so i'm
hopeful
that we can find an accommodation
that where we can save the lives of
people in for example
in uh in libya okay so um
here's the thing that's the wrong place
indeed
they're digging in the wrong place so
joe biden doesn't know where he is and
he doesn't know where syria is
also he gets very angry when you ask him
simple questions
so joe biden was asked about
what he is going to do to stand up to
the russians and the chinese and
and joe biden was like growling at the
reporters he's like i need more time i
mean first of all i don't know what
happened to his voice here
suddenly he became one of the demons
from poulter guys this is real weird
stuff
you've kept in place some trump-era
steel and aluminum sanctions and i
wanted to ask you
when you're having these conversations
with european
allies who are very concerned about
these sanctions how do you justify that
and what are your plans 120 days give me
a break
need time 120 days
give me a break need time
dude what is going on what is happening
right now
okay and it was consistent it was like
across the entire g7
so first of all the g7 is always weird
right you always get these weird
pictures of these world leaders
awkwardly associating with one another
this time they opened their picture uh
their opening picture was of the g7
leaders in cornwall like on a beach in
cornwall
and they look like they just beamed it
down except that angela merkel was
wearing a red jacket so she's the one
who goes first right is usually the way
that this works
but joe biden just he's not with us
okay in the middle of one of his press
conferences he starts talking again
about how he's going to get in trouble
with his own staff if he answers
unapproved questions he does this all
the time by the way
he's saying the quiet part out loud he's
actually reading the stage direction
from the teleprompter
so here is joe biden doing that again
uh i'm sorry i'm gonna get in trouble
with staff i don't do this the right way
jennifer jacob bloomberg
i have to i have to i'll only answer
questions from the people my staff
tells me to answer broccoli
okay and then he um he tried to
introduce
the presidents of south africa after
boris johnson already had
leading the entire g7 to laugh at him
things are going swimmingly
um
so boris johnson reminds joe biden the
president of the united states that he
already introduced the person that joe
biden just tried to introduce
everybody starts laughing at joe biden
and joe biden awkwardly starts laughing
along
yes all is well on the international
stage um joe biden got lost in the wrong
cafe
and had to be ushered away by a young
female aide apparently
uh this this was put out by itv news so
he's just walking around
the g7 he's supposed to be in a
particular place where is his staff
what are they doing he just wanders into
a cafe and everybody's looking at him
like
what is going on why is the president of
the united states wandering around in
this cafe
asking for toilet paper or something
here is the president of your united
states
wandering around in a cafe before being
led away like a small child by an aide
how are your meetings going in cornwall
mr president
how are your meetings going here in
cornwall
they all are laughing at him there comes
his aide she's like
she's like come on joe come on come on
unbelievable unbelievable then there
were his
i mean his aides have a rough job i mean
it's a tough job i understand i have
children of my own
his aides we're trying to shoo away the
press there's a biden mccrone photo
up and his aides are like we need the
cameras to go away because
we need to get joe needs a nap joe needs
a rest just a little fussy
gotta get him his bottle here here are
his aides trying to show away the press
thank you thank you thank you
and his aides are like get out of here
go leave
now is not the time joe needs to lie
down
my god yes yes things are great by the
way you want to know the reason that the
europeans are very pro joe biden
because he is giving them all the things
that he that they want including taxes
on american corporations
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right
you should but first like and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video